Seems like everybody's got a price.
I wonder how they sleep at night...
...when the sale comes first and the truth comes second.
Just stop for a minute and smile.
Why is everybody so serious,...
...acting so dang mysterious?
Got your shades on your eyes and your heels so high,...
...you can't even have a good time.
Everybody look to the left,...
...everybody look to the right.
Can you feel that yeah, we're paying with love tonight.
It's not about the money, money, money.
We don't need your money, money, money.
Just wanna make the world dance,...
...forget about the price tag.
Ain't about the cha-ching, cha-ching,...
...ain't about the, no, bling, bling.
Wanna make the world dance,...
...forget about the price tag.